john a les sérigraphies on avait la
route et les fluides finalement chez toi
nicolas mon chéri tu vas jouer pour
plein de cannes où on va faire plusieurs
défis dans la rue à cette fois il y
aurait un cadeau à gagner le premier jeu
il est très simple ce sera pour benhaim
savoir tout de suite je vais je vais
d'abord alors le cadeau en fait non il
faut que je tire au sort les cadeaux
puisque je suis content
alors le cadeau tu vas pas jouer pour du
tout pour ce que je t'ai dit tu vas
jouer et si je l'avais senti un appareil
photo instantanée j'avais senti je
l'avais senti fêtera ses treize fois tu
gagnerais benhaim vous allez devoir
sortir dans la rue et partager un mikado
avec un bel inconnu avec sans les mains
d'accord 5h10 extrémités vous allez
arrêter quelqu'un dans la rue et vous
mangez un mikado gamna jusqu'à jusqu'à
s'élève qu'à donner comme sortiront pas
comme les autres policiers non non ça
c'est tout vous l'avez vous l'avez
arrêter comme ça la dame la mairie non
je préfère savoir guillaume je connais
j'allais à la faute
on y voit les bourguignonnes elle en
fera 2 alors moi je vais le faire avec
vous je suis parti parce que julien adam
je veux dire non non non on se souvient
de celle où l'état doit faire du jogging
vasily la toile on va jouer à des coups
là un ordinateur portable convertible
360° du bien ce qu'il va falloir faire
il va falloir faire
torse nu pour les garçons un car wash
si attendre est arrêté une voiture et
faire un carnage sexy ça peut être fille
ou garçon
je fais tourner la roue attention et je
suis dedans au loyer je suis devant les
gars complètement
[Applaudissements]
allez
tout le monde est en a trop
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais je n'ai pas tenus alors il se
lavait la voiture équipe était très sexy
du nu sur scène très sexy ça tu fais
c'est si je peux être assez que si oui
alors rival jaloux tu vas
[Applaudissements]
quant à eux
safrana plateau numérique
brabham entendu
je suis né à tébessa
ça va chier alors les cherry on va jouer
pour un stade où il faut danser un zouk
zouk avec un moustachu au statut vous
aurez de 60 secondes pour trouver un
moustachu savoie le chéri de seconde
d'accord les chéris je veux ni dominique
je fais on le fait comme ça on fait tout
ensemble ce ce sera toi qui verra le sou
à vif le moustachu non mais non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un bisou le bisou le bisou le bisou le
bisou
[Applaudissements]
je croise acquis par à quelle manie